This video is sponsored by KiwiCo.
Hello the internet, I am Gav.
In this video, we're gonna
be recreating a viral TikTok
that a lot of you have very
kindly sent me, I thank you,
of an Apple being levitated
on a jet of compressed air.
Due to a phenomenon
called the Coanda effect,
it should just stay exactly
in place on the compressed air
until eventually it goes
a little bit too fast
for itself and pops.
Sounds like an excellent
subject for the Phantom.
So why don't we give it a go?
There certainly seems to
be some technique to it.
This is 150 PSI compressor
but it seems to be less about the power
and more about the slow
build to keep it stable
'cause if I end up just flooring it,
it bounces up and down
like this and loses speed.
It's all about sort of
getting it right on the edge
and then you can hear it revving up.
It's actually, the sound
is the only indication
I have that I know I'm doing it right.
And then eventually the
sound goes high enough
and you just got to clench
and hope for the best.
So this apple is able to
perfectly defy gravity.
As the jet of air bounces
off one side of the apple,
it creates an area of low pressure
between the air and the curved surface.
This area of low pressure
effectively pulls in the airflow
allowing it to follow
the curve of the apple.
At this point, as the
curve surface of the apple
is putting a force on the air,
the air exerts an equal and opposite force
upward on the apple
and that's why it's able to
perfectly float in place.
Whoa, this effect only works on objects
with a curved surface.
So if this was a mutated cube apple,
it wouldn't work at all.
It's pretty crazy, to my
eye when I'm looking at it,
I'm just looking at a blur
and then like one frame of
my eyes later, it's gone.
It's like someone's just edited out
a moment of my life there.
It's so fast.
Bloody hell, look at
the RPM on that thing.
That is baking.
Well this camera's not fast enough.
That is rapid.
It's moving fast in slow motion.
I need to cool Alabama.
All right, it's been a few days
and Destin has come
through with this 2511.
We now have access to 28,000
frames a second at 720p
which should be a lot better
for seeing the rotation
and potentially seeing
where the crack starts.
Make sure you subscribe
to Smarter Everyday
because he's always helping me out.
Just gonna do a bit of
apple art on some of these
so we can better track the rotation.
Damn it.
Awe, it's amazing, wow.
You can actually see the skin of the apple
ripping in this, at this speed.
That one gave me a rollicking on the hand.
If I wasn't wearing gloves,
that one would really hurt I think.
Okay, so now we can
roughly estimate how fast
the apple was spinning by
timing how long it takes
for this line to come
back around to the arrow.
This was the final rotation of the apple
and based on the sound it was making
and the fact that it exploded,
I'm gonna assume this was
the fastest rotation as well.
One full rotation in 9.1 milliseconds.
That's 109 rotations per second,
which reveals the apples nope speed
to be 6565 RPM.
That was something, that was very sweaty,
very loud and slightly terrifying work
but I do think we've got some
lovely looking footage there
especially with the 2511.
We saw a lot more that we didn't see
at 1000 frames a second,
like the skin ripping
almost as though the inside
of the apple has already split
And the skin is just the
final thing to give away.
Absolutely mental and I
think I do now have to invest
in some sort of long handled mop
to clean the ceiling and the walls.
Made a right mess in this one.
I think it was worth it though.
I think it was worth seeing.
I've never seen it that slow.
Now I'd like to talk to you
about the sponsor of this video, KiwiCo.
KiwiCo is a wonderful
service encouraging kids
to learn from home.
Each box contains an
engaging and fun project
or toy to construct.
Here you can enjoy footage of me
constructing this glowing pendulum.
KiwiCo offers eight subscription lines
each catering to different
age groups and topics
and every box contains
everything you'll need
for the project,
so no need for any extra
journeys to the store.
KiwiCo is also a fantastic
option for a holiday gift.
Every completed KiwiCo
crate is an opportunity
to inspire a lifetime of
curiosity and learning
and they're great for the
family to do together.
If you would like to support
The Slow Mo Guys channel,
make sure you check out
kiwico.com/slowmoguys.
At that link, you'll be
able to get your first month
of KiwiCo for free.
Thank you very much for
watching this video.
If you liked the footage you saw
and you're interested
in slow-mo in general,
make sure you subscribe.
We've got new merch and that's about it.
I'll see you in the next video.